Strange it's time in 10
days nothing can prepare you
for the truth everything you've
ever known led you to this moment
stephen strange the illuminati will see you now
you open the doorway to the multiverse on
may 6th we don't know who or what bought food
okay i thought one strange was bad
enough marvel studios doctor strange
Welcome back everyone this will be my new doctor
strange multiverse of madness video right after
i just posted one marvel posted a bunch of extra
new footage a lot of you were also asking about
the living tribunal it's also featured during
the trailers along with a bunch of other really
big cosmic characters it's all tied to a big
deleted scene from avengers infinity war that
i did a video about a billion years ago because
it is really cool to see marvel doing big cosmic
characters in the mcu finally we also saw
a version of the living tribunal during the
loki series i'll talk about what's going on with
the variant of iron man that they're featuring
during the movie with all these different
ultron robots from the alternate universe
and all the scenes of the illuminati during the
trailer if you're brand new to the channel on
doing an imax ticket giveaway for the movie all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just leave all your theories about the cosmic
concepts in the mcu going forward after this
i will do full videos for the movie next week
after it comes out in theaters and i'll post my
non-spoilery review after we're allowed to post
it i think i'm supposed to see it sometime early
next week as of me posting this video today i have
not seen the movie yet i'll start with the living
tribunal stuff then i'll talk about the variant
of iron man and then the crazy skeletons and all
the easter eggs from the posters with all the
different variants that people are talking about
the scene with the living tribunal also seems like
it happens really quickly like blink and you'll
miss it when mcu doctor strange and america chavez
have just been saved by defender strange before he
gets turned into a marvel zombie big deep cut for
marvel's what if episodes we're actually going to
be getting what if season 2 episodes later
this year too i'll be doing full videos for
but it's going to be a little while before we get
a trailer zombies great idea he loves them it's
not them what came with the zombies they've just
tried to get the book of the vashanti and use it
because doctor strange is trying to get their
magical power which is a huge upgrade for him
and use it to counter scarlet witch's chaos magic
in the magic of the darkhold the movie does invoke
the vashanti in a really big way the book of the
vishanti i just did a big video on why they're
such a huge deal in the mcu and how they're kind
of like the gods from moon knight in thor love
and thunder so i'll add a link for that video in
the description below too and after america chavez
punches another hole between universes so they
can escape it seems like in the inner dimensional
space like as they're porting between different
universes they pass a really quick blink and
you'll miss it version of the mcu living tribunal
which is a really huge deal like i said a huge
deep cut for a giant deleted scene from avengers
infinity war the one we saw during the loki series
was a different version so we'll talk about the
infinity war one first because he was an important
character during the thanos infinity gauntlet
storyline which they adapted for the movie itself
and because this video is also kind of meant
to be an iron man variant video this also ties
in with the mcu version of iron man in their
battle on titan with thanos during infinity war
during that battle doctor strange uses a bunch of
really cool magical spells that are meant to be
deep cuts from the comics like the crimson bands
of sidorak he also splits himself into a bunch of
different aspects to confuse thanos it was meant
to be one of the cooler magical battles during
the movie a lot of you've also probably detected
there's another easter egg for that spell like
they brought it back again with the marvel zombies
version of defender strange in the doctor strange
2 trailer where he creates all the skeletal
versions of himself getting ready to attack
everybody and go crazy so multiple infinity war
and end game callbacks during doctor strange 2.
but back during the battle on titan doctor strange
was going to pull the same trick on thanos during
the fight that the ancient one pulled on him
when he first came to kamar taj sending him
on the magical mystery tour of the multiverse
and through different dimensions in different
universes at the end of the multiverse tour doctor
strange was going to take thanos to the mcu living
tribunal to be judged in the cosmic sense like
being judged by the actual mcu multiverse they
said they had to delete the scene because the
movie has started to get too long and it was just
too confusing for the non-hardcore audiences like
who's this character why is this such a big deal
it would have required a bunch of extra scenes on
top of that to explain who the living tribunal was
because this was the first time you were seeing
him and thanos would still have beaten him at
the end of the day escape judgment because
he was always going to snap the full infinity
gauntlet with all six infinity stones at the
end of the movie that was never gonna change
so they said it just became too extra and had
to go the version the living tribunal that we
see during the loki series is during episode 5
on the planet at the end of time basically was
the dumping ground for everything from timelines
that kang wanted to get rid of or he who remains
version of kang but if you've been watching
the marvel movies since the beginning since
that first iron man film you know that they have a
long history of bringing back those deleted scenes
deleted concepts and repurposing them for future
movies in different contexts like things that they
weren't able to do in previous movies but thought
were really cool they brought back in a bigger way
in future movies and the living tribunal is just
the next example of that the living tribunal is
like this vast powerful humanoid cosmic entity
who has existed as long as the universe itself
it was created when the multiverse was created
its entire purpose is to be the judge jury and
executioner for the entire multiverse it protects
the multiverse against an imbalance of mystical
forces like we see happening during doctor strange
ii it acts to prevent one universe from amassing
more powers than the others threatening the other
universes sometimes it'll also micromanage and try
to prevent an overwhelming imbalance of good or
evil in any particular universe but typically when
matters involve only a single universe it'll leave
things to the lesser cosmic entities that live in
that one particular universe scarlet witch and all
the variants threaten the entire multiverse during
the movie all of reality so it makes sense that
they would invoke the living tribunal in some way
for the film they've changed its appearance just
a little bit for the movie so they've shown it
as three different heads but in the comics it's
actually one single body with three different
faces one of the faces is totally uncovered one is
partially covered and the other is fully covered
with that cloth that you see on top of it because
it's meant to protect the sanctity of all reality
of the entire multiverse there's only one of it
in the entire multiverse as opposed to lesser gods
like thor where there's a different variant in
every single universe he's meant to be one of the
most powerful cosmic level characters in existence
next to the beyonders eternity the celestials
the one above all and the cosmos the cosmos is
like the living entity that embodies the entire
multiverse the loki series implied that a version
of kang could be more powerful theoretically than
the living tributal or the beyonders for
example would be able to kill the living
tribunal but pretty much everybody else even the
celestials would have a hard time taking it down
but talking about what's going on with iron man
during the trailer so we see all these alternate
universe ultron looking robots escorting doctor
strange to see professor x there's a bunch of new
scenes of him with those robots going to see the
illuminati there's been a lot of reports people
have been asking me about this past week saying
that tom cruise is not playing a version of iron
man during the movie which shouldn't be that big
of a surprise i mean tom cruise is a huge actor
it's no surprise that he would not show up in
a marvel movie but there's a lot of confusion
people think that the rumor says that there's no
iron man in the movie anywhere but the report just
says that tom cruise is not in the movie not that
the movie doesn't reference any kind of version of
iron man at all because that is where these robots
would have come from from this alternate universe
version of iron man so there is a version of
iron man that the movie references but it was
probably never gonna be tom cruise portraying
that character and probably out of respect for
robert downey jr and mcu iron man i wouldn't
be surprised if this iron man variant is only
a tiny part of the movie like we see a ton of his
robots especially scarlet witch ripping through a
ton of his robots r.i.p to these ultron robots
but they might only reference iron man himself
or if we do wind up seeing a version of him he's
only a tiny part of the movie and it definitely
will not be robert downey jr's version of iron
man the iron man armor war series next year will
invoke more of the legacy of mcu iron man because
roadie is going to be one of the main characters
it's going to be all about a villain taking iron
man's technology and using it in really terrible
ways and them having to stop them in down the road
we will see more iron man stuff happening around
whatever version of secret wars they do with
the mcu multiverse there's a lot of questions
about what's going on with the skeletons during
the trailer too because a lot of people have
been posting memes about quicksilver like oh yeah
quicksilver's in the film because it is a skeleton
and mcu quicksilver died a long time ago but
like i said the actual skeletons are meant to be
another easter egg for the marvel zombies version
of defender strange in the infinity war scene of
him splitting himself into a bunch of different
astral aspects this also turns into another big
sam raimi easter egg for the way that he films
a lot of his horror movies like the evil dead
easter eggs when the camera whips past this zombie
version of defender strange and he swipes at the
camera like it's in first person perspective you
see all the skeletal looking astral projections
flying past him to attack the others at this big
dark hole temple and you see them again in mcu
scarlet witch's eye as it zooms in on her eyeball
the reflection in her eyeball are the skeletons
there's more footage of doctor strange with
the red hair christine palmer variant in one
of the sanctums performing a big spell floating
in the air there's more footage of him fighting
the sinister strange variant in his sanctum you
can actually see that they've changed his magical
energy to purple they've given all the variants
different colors of magic mostly to help the
casual fans tell things apart when things get
really crazy on screen with all the big magical
battles but the other reason to do that will be
just to show that they are each weaving different
kinds of spells and using different types of magic
drawing their magical power from different sources
but if there's anything in the trailer footage
that i didn't talk about in the video that you
have a lot of questions about or any big easter
eggs that you spotted just write them below in
the comments my full moon knight episode 5 video
will post next make sure you enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click here
for that moon knight episode 5 video i'll update
the link as soon as i post the video and click
here for my brand new guardians of the galaxy
3 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!